cashing in on his book deal about
pandemic leadership he called it
republicans calling it blood money
after tax returns show the governor
could rake in more than five million
dollars
that's the book he wrote as thousands
died in nursing new york nursing homes
and he is now being investigated for
potentially covering up those deaths
while he was writing the book and here's
the thing
greg big payday hardly any sales
this drives me nuts you know almost
that's almost as much as what i made on
the plus
and i sold books i mean my god
i i mean i earned that yacht i wish no
this drives me crazy i don't understand
the economics
of the book of the book business it's
just
based on somebody's name and influence
and power
i think you know clemson's donated a
third of it to covet relief i guess
he should donate it all to the families
of the rest home victims
uh because i i don't know here's the
weird thing about and that'll shut up
this guy has two scandals going at once
and he's still there it's incredible
he's uncancelable
he's just skating on through juan yeah
yeah well you know i think cuomo's
publishing house they made a big mistake
dana i think they bought high and you
know
stock market terms they bought high and
now
the market's falling out they can't even
sell as you said the books not selling
but you know this reminds me i think few
books about politics
written by politicians really are worth
reading uh
i think you know even people like
president trump said you know he didn't
even read his own book
he didn't write it either but i mean
politicians do this all the time
and what the big racket now is they just
you know
have some of their supporters buy it in
bulk sales
and then it's like a back door
contribution to me it's
it's becomes a racket we can see it
clearly now picking up on the idea that
powerful people when they're hot
get these exorbitant uh up front
uh you know deals contracts from
publishers digging i guess
they just write it off maybe i want to
know
you know i'm not a fan of lists but it
sold 48 000 copies i would like a list
of people who actually paid
money to be lied to by this murderous
despot
who when you were getting it for free
for more than a year
and by the way let's not forget this
person who killed sixteen thousand
elderly people lied and stonewalled and
sicked his goons on the grieving
families and then was groping up on
women
allegedly he wrote this in the middle of
a pandemic
while the entire state that he governed
was suffering
but i haven't i want to add one thing
greg you'll love this
in terms of the idiots who work at these
publishing houses
this is from john levine at the new york
post the book was published by crown a
division of penguin random house
and those staffers random house staffers
cried at the plans to publish jordan
peterson
they were sobbing at work what was the
reaction to this
yeah with little worms and crowns
published some great books uh charles
krauthammer's book was there
um for example um i don't know anyway
jesse you've got a book coming out
how does how do you feel about all this
you ready for this crazy book world
dana he wrote a book about how he saved
new york i saved the world
right i mean more than five million
absolutely five million i'm not gonna
lie i'm with greg i'm a little upset
about this but juan is actually right
it's a grease job think about last
spring
cuomo could have been the nominee or at
least he was the 24
to 2024 nominee so you're looking at
basically
paying off a potential president a
democratic president
that's where his trajectory was so they
think let's get in good and maybe
random house will get the memoirs you
know the presidential memoirs it was
like an investment
and they don't realize that you're more
likely to be president
i know who i am
i'm trying to pump up those book sales
how jesse
saved the world one more thing hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else